- [David] Hello grammarians,
today we're going to talk
about two of my, well, I
don't know if I'd call them
favorite, but two of my most
frequently confused words.
I make this mistake all the time
and I think it's important
to keep it straight.
Affect and effect are
two very different words.
What is the difference you might ask.
Well, that's why I'm here.
To sum it up, let's just put
the TL, DR right at the top.
Affect is a verb, just
think of that as a verb.
And effect, think of that as a noun.
It's more complicated
than that, obviously,
but most of the time, when
you're looking at these
two words and you're trying to decide,
oh which one do I use?
Affect is a verb, effect is a noun.
That's the too long,
didn't read of this video,
and who reads a video, but
this is your key takeaway.
Let me give you some examples.
Let's take this sentence:
the drought had a nasty
blank on Angela's crops.
Now, both of these words
mean something happened,
right?
They both mean that there was a change,
but effect with an E is
the result of that change,
and affect with an A, or affect,
is the change agent if that makes sense.
So, we're looking at this sentence:
the drought had a nasty
blank on Angela's crops.
We know we need to use one of those.
Well, we're signaling here
by using the article a
and the adjective nasty that
we're looking for a noun.
So, we'd wanna say: the
drought had a nasty effect.
Another way to think of
this is effect with an E
is the same way as saying result.
Similarly, if we wanted to
write this sentence again,
but with affect, with a verb, we'd say:
the drought affected Angela's crops.
So, affect, we're using it as a verb,
effect we're using it as a noun.
And I'm exaggerating the
pronunciation of those
just to give you the distinction.
Now, of course there are
always obnoxious exceptions,
let's cover them briefly,
but just bear in mind that
these are pretty rare.
Number one: the word
effect with an E as verb.
When you see this as a verb
it usually means to create.
The way I usually see this is
in the phrase effect change,
which really means to bring about change.
Effect here means to create.
So, Kimiko hoped that the
new mayor would effect change
in her town.
What we're saying here
is really, make change.
When we say effect as a verb
that really just means to make.
And the other obnoxious exception
is affect as a noun,
which is like a psychology term,
it really means someone's personality.
So, for example Percy had a smug affect.
And that just means his
personality is smug.
Now, I wanna hit again
that these are exceptions
and they're pretty rare.
I would caution avoiding
them most of the time.
I think your big takeaway
is that affect is a verb
and effect is a noun, and
yes these exceptions exist
but I think in the interest
of clarity, you need
to be very certain when you're using them.
Because affect here as a
noun is professional jargon,
frankly, this is psychologist talk
and that means it's a very
particular kind of English,
it's to be used in a specific context.
Likewise, effect as a verb, frankly,
I don't what you get out of this.
I would just say make, frankly,
I'm not sure it's worth the confusion.
But that's just a style
tip, obviously it's still
grammatical to use it that way,
you just have to be careful of confusion.
So, what's the takeaway?
Affect is a verb, effect is a noun,
but there are exceptions.
You can learn anything.
David out.